Quiero comenzar reflexionando sobre este aparato,
el teléfono que probablemente tienen en el bolsillo ahora mismo.
Más del 40 % de los estadounidenses revisan sus teléfonos
los primeros cinco minutos tras despertar por la mañana,
y luego lo revisan otras 50 veces durante del día.
Los adultos consideran este aparato una necesidad.
Pero ahora quiero que se lo imaginen en las manos de un niño de tres años,
y como sociedad, nos ponemos ansiosos.
Los padres están muy preocupados
que este aparato va a atrofiar el desarrollo social de sus hijos;
que va a impedir que se activen y se muevan,
que de alguna manera va a perturbar su niñez.
Así que, quiero desafiar esta actitud.
Yo puedo imaginar un futuro
donde nos emocione ver a un niño de preescolar
interactuando con una pantalla.
Estas pantallas pueden activar a los niños aún más.
Tienen el poder de darnos más información sobre lo que está aprendiendo un niño
que una prueba estandarizada.
Y esta es la idea alocada:
yo creo que las pantallas tienen el poder
de impulsar más conversaciones reales entre padres e hijos.
Soy una defensora insólita en esta causa.
Estudié literatura infantil
porque iba a trabajar con niños y con libros.
Pero hace como 20 años,
tuve una experiencia que cambió mi enfoque.
Ayudé a dirigir un estudio sobre niños de edad preescolar y sitios web.
Y al entrar me asignaron a una niña de tres años llamada María.
María nunca antes había visto una computadora.
Así que lo primero que hice fue enseñarle a utilizar el ratón,
y cuando activé la pantalla lo movió a través de la pantalla,
y se detuvo en un personaje llamado X el Búho.
Y cuando hizo esto,
el búho alzó el ala y la saludó.
María soltó el ratón, se levantó, dio un brinco
y comenzó a devolverle el saludo frenéticamente.
Su conexión con ese personaje fue visceral.
Eso no era una experiencia de pantalla pasiva.
Era una experiencia humana.
Y era perfectamente apropiada para una niña de tres años.
Desde entonces he trabajado en PBS Kids más de 15 años,
y mi trabajo se centra en aprovechar el poder de la tecnología
como algo positivo en la vida de los niños.
Yo creo que como sociedad estamos dejando pasar una gran oportunidad.
Estamos dejando que nuestro miedo y escepticismo sobre estos aparatos
nos impida entender su potencial en la vida de nuestros niños.
El miedo a los niños y la tecnología no es nada nuevo;
ya hemos pasado por esto antes.
Hace más de 50 años el debate se desató
por el nuevo medio de comunicación dominante: la televisión.
¿Esa caja en la sala?
Puede que separe a los niños unos de otros.
Puede que los mantenga alejados del mundo exterior.
Pero este fue el momento en que Fred Rogers,
el veterano presentador de La Vecindad del Señor Rogers,
desafió a la sociedad a que viera la televisión como una herramienta,
una herramienta con poder para promover el crecimiento emocional.
Esto es lo que hizo:
miró hacia afuera de la pantalla y mantuvo una conversación,
como si estuviese hablándole a cada niño de manera individual
sobre los sentimientos.
Y luego hacía una pausa
y los dejaba reflexionando.
Su influencia puede verse hoy en todo el panorama mediático,
pero en su momento fue revolucionario.
Cambió el modo en que vemos la televisión en la vida de los niños.
Hoy no es una sola caja,
los niños están rodeados de aparatos.
Y también soy madre, entiendo el sentimiento de ansiedad.
Pero quiero que analicemos los tres temores principales
que tienen los padres,
y ver si podemos cambiar el enfoque
hacia la oportunidad que presenta cada uno.
Bien.
Temor número uno:
"Las pantallas son pasivas."
"Van a evitar que los niños sean activos y se muevan."
Chris Kratt y Martin Kratt son dos hermanos zoólogos
que tienen un programa sobre animales llamado "Kratts Salvajes."
Y se acercaron al equipo de PBS diciendo:
"¿Podemos hacer algo con esas cámaras
incorporadas en todos los aparatos hoy en día?
¿Podrían esas cámaras capturar el patrón de juego natural de un niño:
jugando a ser un animal?"
Así que empezamos con murciélagos.
Y cuando los niños empezaron a jugar,
les encantó verse en la pantalla con alas.
Pero, ¿cuál fue mi parte favorita?
Cuando terminó el juego y apagamos las pantallas
Los niños seguían siendo murciélagos.
Seguían volando por el cuarto,
seguían virando de izquierda a derecha para atrapar mosquitos.
Y se acordaban de los datos.
Se acordaban que los murciélagos vuelan por la noche.
Y recordaban que cuando éstos duermen,
se cuelgan al revés y doblan sus alas hacia adentro.
Este juego definitivamente hizo a los niños moverse.
Pero además, ahora cuando los niños salen afuera y
ven un pájaro, piensan:
"¿Cómo ese pájaro vuela distinto a mí, cuando vuelo yo como murciélago?"
La tecnología digital dio lugar al aprendizaje personificado
que los niños ahora pueden incorporar a su mundo.
Temor número dos:
"Jugar un juego en esas pantallas es una pérdida de tiempo.
Va a distraer a los niños de sus actividades escolares."
Los desarrolladores de juegos saben
que se puede aprender mucho sobre la habilidad de un jugador
viendo los datos almacenados.
¿Dónde hizo una pausa el jugador?
¿Dónde cometió pequeños errores antes de encontrar la respuesta correcta?
Mi equipo quería tomar esas herramientas y aplicarlas al aprendizaje académico.
Nuestro productor en Boston, WGBH,
creó una serie de juegos de Jorge, el Curioso
enfocados en matemáticas.
Y los investigadores pusieron a 80 niños de edad preescolar a jugar con ellos.
Luego le dieron a cada uno de estos 80 niños
una prueba estandarizada de matemáticas.
Pudimos ver muy pronto
que estos juegos de hecho ayudaban a los niños
a entender algunos puntos clave.
Pero nuestros compañeros en UCLA querían que profundizáramos.
Ellos se centran en análisis de datos y evaluación de estudiantes.
Y ellos querían tomar los datos almacenados de estos juegos
para utilizarlos y así para predecir los resultados de matemáticas del niño.
Así que hicieron una red neuronal
y básicamente entrenaron una computadora para utilizar estos datos,
y estos son los resultados.
Este es un subconjunto de las notas estandarizadas de los niños.
Y esto
es la predicción de la computadora de la nota de cada niño,
basada en los juegos de Jorge, el Curioso.
Las predicciones son asombrosamente precisas,
especialmente si se considera
que estos juegos no fueron construidos para evaluar.
El equipo que realizó este estudio cree que juegos como este
pueden revelarnos más sobre el aprendizaje cognitivo del niño
que una prueba estandarizada.
¿Qué tal si los juegos pudieran reducir el tiempo de examinación en el aula?
¿Qué tal si pudieran reducir la ansiedad que generan los exámenes?
¿Cómo podrían darle a los maestros un vistazo con información
para enfocar mejor el aprendizaje individualizado?
El tercer temor que quiero abordar
en mi opinión es el mayor.
Y es este:
"Estas pantallas me están separando de mi hijo."
Vamos a plantear un escenario:
Digamos que eres un padre,
y necesitas 25 minutos de tiempo sin interrupciones
para preparar la cena.
Y para lograrlo le das la tableta a tu hijo de tres años.
Este es el momento en que probablemente te sientes muy culpable
por lo que acabas de hacer.
Pero imagina esto:
veinte minutos después recibes un mensaje de texto
en ese móvil que siempre está al alcance .
Y dice: "Alex acaba de emparejar tres palabras que riman.
Pídele jugar este juego contigo.
¿Puedes pensar en una palabra que rime con 'gato'?
¿Y qué tal con 'pelota'?"
En nuestras investigaciones, cuando los padres reciben
consejos sencillos como este, les hace sentirse en control.
Se emocionan mucho
al jugar estos juegos durante la cena con sus hijos.
Y a los niños les encanta también.
No solo les parece magia que sus padres sepan
a qué habían estado jugando,
sino que a los niños les encanta jugar con sus padres.
El simple hecho de hablar con los niños sobre los medios
puede ser increíblemente poderoso.
El verano pasado, la Universidad de Texas Tech
publicó en un estudio que sugería que el show "Daniel Tigre" promovía
el desarrollo de la empatía entre niños.
Pero había un pequeño truco en este estudio:
el mayor beneficio se daba cuando los padres
hablaban con sus hijos sobre lo que habían visto.
Ni tan solo con verlo
ni solo con hablarlo, era suficiente.
La clave era la combinación de ambas cosas.
Así que cuando leí este estudio, comencé a pensar
que rara vez los padres con hijos en preescolar hablan con ellos
sobre el contenido de lo que están jugando y viendo.
Así que decidí probar con mi hijo de cuatro años.
Le dije,
"¿Estuviste jugando a un juego de autos hace un rato?"
Y Benjamín se espabiló y dijo:
"!Sí! ¿Y viste que hice mi auto con un pepinillo?
Era muy difícil abrir el maletero."
(Risas)
Esta divertida conversación
sobre lo que era divertido de ese juego y lo que podría ser mejor
continuó hasta que llegamos a la escuela esa mañana.
No estoy aquí para sugerirles que todo el contenido digital es bueno para los niños.
Hay razones de peso para estar preocupados
sobre el tipo de contenido que hay para los niños en esas pantallas.
Y está bien que pensemos en un equilibrio:
¿Dónde encajan las pantallas entre el resto de las cosas
que necesita hacer un niño para crecer y aprender?
Pero cuando nos clavamos en los miedos que nos provocan,
olvidamos de un punto muy importante,
y es que los niños están viviendo en el mismo mundo que nosotros,
el mundo donde los adultos revisan sus teléfonos
más de 50 veces al día.
Las pantallas son parte de la vida de los niños.
Y si fingimos que no lo son,
o si dejamos que el miedo nos abrume,
los niños no van a aprender cómo y por qué usarlos.
¿Qué tal si comenzamos a elevar nuestras expectativas
para estos medios?
¿Qué tal si comenzamos a hablar regularmente con los niños
sobre el contenido en estas pantallas?
¿Qué tal si buscamos el impacto positivo
que esta tecnología puede tener en la vida de nuestros hijos?
Es entonces cuando el potencial de estas herramientas
puede convertirse en realidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)